bueno Valentina es un ambiente de cierre
Aunque todavía quedan visitantes en los
pasillos de corfería aquí en la capital
colombiana vinieron a comprar libros
obviamente a visitar la filmó o atender
a los últimos eventos de esta edición
número 35 pero definitivamente la Feria
Internacional del Libro de Bogotá volvió
a la calma después de un segundo fin de
semana muy intenso era súper difícil de
caminar por la cantidad de gente de sus
últimos días Lo que muestra el gran
interés que suscitó el evento literario
durante esas dos semanas hemos visto a
muchas familias muchos estudiantes a un
Público de todas esas edades de manera
general y del lado de los escritores que
más éxito tuvieron este año también
hemos visto perfiles bastante diferentes
dentro los que llenaron el auditorio más
grande de la filbo podemos destacar a
Mario Mendoza el periodista colombiano a
dos otras colombianas que son las
influencers calle y poche pero también
al politólogo argentino Agustín laje y a
la escritora nigerianas
que hemos grabado aquí en la silbo duda
dentro de los próximos días los
televidentes van a poder escuchar a
muchas personas como Guillermo Arriaga
El guionista y director de cine mexicano
a Mónica Ojeda la escritora ecuatoriana
A la yamila Ribeiro la activista y
periodista brasileña y también a
Barcelona el ilustrador francés entonces
aconsejo a todos los televidentes que
seguirán conectados a France 24